welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka your friendly neighborhood spoiler
man and the title for spider-man 3 has
just hit the web
throughout this video we have a ton of
things to unpack and we're going to be
going over the initial trolling
the title itself and the first looks at
the film that have a lot going on in
them
i will be discussing some of the
apparent leaks for what's behind these
reveals
and how they set up the general arc of
the movie so don't watch if you don't
want any spoilers
now if you're still here and you enjoy
the video then please hit the thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe for all the
up-to-date news on the film as it comes
out
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so first up i'm going to be
discussing a lot of different aspects
around the film in this video
so if you want to swing ahead to a
certain point then time codes are in the
description below
firstly though i feel we need to discuss
the initial titles that hit the internet
yesterday
and made tom holland become one of the
biggest trolls of all time
known for inadvertently spoiling stuff
he posted an
image that looks like it was going to be
called spider-man phone home
shortly after there was one posted for
home wrecker home
slice and spider-man home alone 2 lost
in new york
there were a couple of articles posted
saying that some of these were the real
titles
but they were erased from history faster
than uncle ben in the mcu
but that doesn't mean that they're
completely pointless actually think that
the three different titles are not only
referencing that this is the third
spider-man movie
but also that there will be three
spider-men in the film namely tom
holland
andrew garfield and of course toby
mcguire
it's always pizza time somewhere and it
looks like he's gonna be able to pay
rent for the rest of his life
as from what i've heard marvel paid a
huge amount of money to get the actor on
board
now these titles are of course a bit of
a fun if you like a laugh
and we all know you're like a laugh
however we've been waiting for the real
one which we can now reveal is
drum roll please
[Music]
spider-man no way home
so no home worlds wasn't the title but
this actually seems more intriguing
now it carries a hell of a lot with it
and it is possible that the film
actually ends with peter parker crossing
over into the multiverse
you might remember that when the sony
deal was first announced
that kevin feige said spider-man was the
only character
capable of crossing cinematic universes
now what i kind of take from this is
that peter might actually end up in
another dimension come the end of the
film
and this will allow him to interact with
venom and mobius
from this point he can play with the
sony characters for a bit before
potentially pulling them back into the
main continuity
evan peters and the x-men are likely
being brought across through special
means
so it makes sense that the sony
characters would come across in a
different way too
if you've been following this stuff all
day then you'll know it was meant to be
announced around 2 p.m gmt
and then i got pushed back about three
hours and then it got pushed back again
i was literally sat on my laptop the
whole time as i was shutting it down i
shut it down
and got the notification that it had
been announced i think a lot of people
are going to have a lot of different
interpretations on it
but let me know what yours is in the
comments below yeah
okay and as for the first look images
these actually have a lot going on in
them
on the surface it just seems like
they're three shots of our three high
school protagonists
but if that's what you think yeah then
you're wrong and get the hell out of
here
now in the photos there's peter parker
mj in a lovely beanie and jacket combo
and ned who's looking trim man's lost
weight now they appear to be in a dark
and dusty rundown building
and throughout the shots it looks like
they make their way into the basement
before booting up their laptop
now i don't know how they managed to get
wi-fi in the worst part of the house
but i can imagine that they're looking
over the internet to see the backlash
that the reveal at the end of far from
home has caused
theo was of course ousted as spider-man
i think this movie will very much be
about the web head coming to grips that
he's now one of the most wanted men in
manhattan
after john wick of course and there's
that little dog saying this is fine meme
on the laptop
and this of course is a nod to how
peter's entire world is crashing down
around him
though initially it doesn't seem like
there's anything too big of a reveal in
the images
if you spend your life just staring over
things like i do because
you don't have a life then you'll notice
a lot of things going on
now now come here and have a look have a
proper look now
are you looking now look closely at the
floor yeah and you'll notice there's a
distinct pattern on it there's also
lamp shades there and both of these are
key features in dr strange's sanctum
sanctorum
the place looks very run down and it's
likely that strange hasn't really had
the time to give it a proper clean
after the events of the snap and one
division which yeah the guy's definitely
gonna be in it
now from what i've heard on the film
peter goes to strange at one point in
the movie
and asks to help him cover up his
identity things have gotten far too
tough
and strange agrees that it's a lot for
the character so he erases the knowledge
from
everyone's mind on the planet this
happened in the comic book story one
more day
after its reveal in civil war but
similar to both those arcs
this movie has repercussions apparently
strange doing this
actually breaks the multiverse and thus
villains like electro and doc
awk are able to come across from there
peter has to get alternate versions of
spider-man to help him defeat the bad
guys
and it leads to a massive showdown at
the end of the movie
i'm not 100 on that but it does make
sense
as it ties in heavily with the comic
books and also sets up the multiverse of
madness
we've also seen behind the scenes looks
where peter is going about his day
anonymously
which i don't think would happen if
everyone knew that he was in fact
spider-man
in the photographs we can also see what
looks to be the shadow of a head
and the three looking up the stairs to
what is likely strange at the top of
them
therefore i do think it lines up but let
me know if you've heard differently
and we also learned that there are some
courtroom attendees that are currently
being cast
and thus it seems like the stories about
matt murdock being peter parker's liar
could indeed be true again i'm not 100
on that
but it does make sense and in terms of
daredevil being in the film
there are rumors going around at the
moment that he will be appearing in a
comic book accurate costume
actually really like the netflix look
that the character had
so i kind of hope it's not too big of a
deviation from that
the black and red worked really well for
me and if worse comes to worst i hope
they at least bring the curl across
i'm guessing that it's gonna be all red
and probably similar to spandex
though they could go with the yellow and
red one that looks similar to a box's
outfit
that his father of course used to wear
now i really hope this ties in with the
netflix shows
as i love most of them yeah even the bad
ones
daredevil was actually very very good at
though and i
absolutely loved the first season of
jessica jones the punisher
and luke cage it's also rumored that
jones and the punisher will be making
their way over to the mcu
in some form or another and hopefully
the other characters come across
too as though they weren't all amazing i
think there's a lot that the studio can
do with them
as for the first second title i think
it's awesome that they finally let us
know exactly what's going on
i was expecting stuff to come out at the
end of one division
and who knows tom holland might even
appear in it in some form or another
i know that's a long shot but the show
is supposed to be setting up the events
of this film and doctor strange too
so there's definitely a possibility that
it could come down the line at some
point
tom holland is one of the biggest stars
in the world right now and though i'm
not sure if i'm allowed to talk about
cherry yet
i did get to see it early and he's done
a really great job of crafting himself
out as an actor
so i think a lot of people will enjoy it
and of course spider-man 3.
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the title and the first look images
so make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize
on the 28th of february in which we're
giving away three copies of the marvel
phase three 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the reveals the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of the commercials for
one division
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over all of them from top to
bottom and pointing out the things you
missed so it's definitely worth watching
if you want to know more
by the way thank you for sitting through
the video i've been paul and i see you
next time
take care peace